foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
yeah so here we are happy Monday
everybody
what a big night huh we've officially
moved to 10 P.M
earlier and earlier and earlier
heck some fans are already talking about
the impact of the change listen up folks
Greg Gutfeld on a cable network beats
all of them okay because he's moderately
entertaining
unless you are an extreme righty he is a
toxic little uh person
little person
easy there Fredo
why does Chris always have that same
desperate look on his face he's he's
like a skydiver realizing that after
jumping he had packed his laundry and
not a parachute
anyway it's July 17th you can now add
fun and truth to this date in history
because our show is a delicious sandwich
of both and boy does this world need
that sandwich right now because it's
full of unanswered questions some things
will never get to the bottom of take the
Curious Case of the White House Coke
it's like an episode of Scooby-Doo but
without the investigative prowess
of a talking dog I mean how hard would
it be for Scooby-Doo to find out whose
Coke that belonged to
I don't think we'll ever figure out
whose Coke it was yeah even the Secret
Service couldn't figure it out zoinks
that's easy the coke is definitely
Hunters you tried to smuggle it in with
all the money he totally got from China
great work gang I guess that wraps
things up then well let's not let good
cocoa to waste
that sounds delicious
see how easy that was but somehow the
White House there were no clues from
inside the world's most secure building
agents found no video no prints no DNA
nothing but hey they did the best they
could right
they did the best they could to to track
down how it got there and and who it
might have belonged to and they just
were not able to come up with any
forensic evidence that that proves it
it's not the kind of thing we want to
see happen if there's things we can do
to prevent that in the future certainly
we'll do that ah of course
wow he was talking really fast did you
notice that what's going on there anyway
so there you have it the case File is as
empty as our vp's head
maybe they should hire the view to
investigate
it's more fodder for the Republican
machine conspiracy
a hunter Biden they are weaponizing
Hunter Biden against his dad as an
effective tool to get his dad to lose
his cool and to get his dad to you know
feel the heartache and those people who
might believe that it was planted for
somebody so that then they could
Advance the hunter Biden narrative yeah
did you catch that according to that
lady
somebody planted the cocaine to frame
Hunter
[Laughter]
because you know what would he want with
cocaine
laughs
yeah if there were only if there were
photographic evidence of Hunter's drug
use
no maybe then we could believe that coke
belonged to him huh
yeah seeing the ladies of the view try
and use deductive reasoning as like
watching Bears try to do geometry
in fact I think the view should get
their own NBC series Law and Order
special units
but I guess the view does know a little
about someone trying to plant Coke
somebody keeps planting diet ones in
their fridge
it was okay now consider the case of the
Gilgo Beach killer
a task force examined 12 year old
evidence and made an arrest on three
murdered women and the slam dunk was of
course DNA from a hair that's 12 years
old remember people if you're gonna
murder someone always wear a hair net
and just like in the Idaho murder case
where the cops got DNA off the sheath of
a knife at the crime scene DNA always at
the crime scene it's like Brian Kilmeade
on the airwaves
he's everywhere and you can't get rid of
him
according to reporting the chances of
that DNA not belonging to Brian coburger
is an octillion to one that is a one
followed by 27 zeros which sounds like
geraldo's Twitter account
that was pretty good
a one followed by 27 zeros I'm kind of
proud of that I might just let it sink
in for a while
that's literally more than every grain
of sand on earth for the chances that
Jesse Waters ever picks up a bar tab
it's funny how that works when the
investigators really want to catch
someone press conferences are held task
forces are formed Mysteries get solved
but apparently not in today's White
House seriously how coke got there is a
mystery but really how our current
president got in the White House is an
even bigger one
I mean
it's harder to believe 80 million people
voted for that mess than it is that
Hunter was snorting lines off a bust in
the Lincoln bedroom and so the Great
White House Caper will soon be the
coldest case since my massage therapist
never made it to his next appointment
yeah these days I guess they're just
things we're never supposed to know for
instance who were the visitors to
Epstein's Island well there's this guy
apparently LinkedIn co-founder Reed
Hoffman he was not only on Epstein's
guest list he also just gave Joe's
campaign 700 Grand
so away goes that story because
obviously does Biden's doj ever
investigate people who give them that
kind of cash will we ever know what
Hunter promised the Chinese businessman
when he demanded 5 million bucks from
him all while saying the big guy you
know the vice president was sitting
beside him and back then without the
help of a Visiting Angel
he got the money a few days later by the
way will we ever learn why the wife of
moscow's Mayor gave Hunter's company 100
million bucks and how much of it went
directly to Joe and how much directly up
Hunter's nose will he ever know why
Ukrainian Energy company barisma was
paying Hunter a million a year but only
until his daddy left office is there a
rule in the FBI handbook that says any
case with the word hunter in it
shouldn't be investigated the guys like
the Bermuda Triangle of the Beltway
things disappear and you don't have to
wear pants
yeah but really all these Mysteries
really answered themselves you know the
answers but there's one total mystery
that I don't think anyone has solved
who exactly is running the country
because America it can't possibly be
this guy
[Applause]
[Music]
let's welcome tonight's guess geez zany
brainy but rarely complaining most of
the Kennedy Saves the World podcast
Kennedy
after the show tonight his mom is taking
him to see Mission Impossible most of
the guy Benson show Guy Benson
she gets sunburned indoors Fox News
contributor Kat Tim
[Applause]
boom my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
guy thank you for being here it's a very
special show for me not for you really
but that's okay you did they conclude
the investigation or did they just
cancel it it seems to me that they just
they didn't it wasn't even a half-assed
effort it was a no asked effort yeah uh
first of all my mom is not letting me
see Mission Impossible because it's
PG-13 so maybe next year uh it's
insulting when the White House comes out
and said oh this was the best we could
do no it's not some people try their
very best and it's not good enough like
the vice president but for other people
like the Secret Service and other
entities that we have in this government
if they wanted to figure out where this
baggie came from they would they don't
want to find it out they don't want to
spend the money so this is what they've
decided to just land on like you know we
don't care anymore that's essentially
what they're telling us yeah because if
you do happen to find out then you're
obligated to say that you know so it's
better just not to do it right just sort
of case close by the way I do appreciate
for all of his faults Chris Cuomo using
the technically correct term little
person I was touched by
you saw that he was going for the m word
right he was going for the m word and he
went
brutal person
I prefer toxic munchkin yes I do that's
what we call each other did O'Reilly say
I was somewhat entertained okay that was
so weird is that he wasn't really that
nice to you yeah exactly then also his
rebuttal for him calling you he said
you're he's moderately you're saying no
no he's toxic yes as if toxic equals
boring yeah that's not true no nobody
looks at like the most toxic
relationship they've ever had I looked
back on that and it's like man what a
boring time yeah that is so true yeah
Pam and Tommy Kim and Kanye yeah they're
all trying to kill Mead and Greg
Brian kilmead and Greg that was an idea
for a show I was dressed as a little dog
I would just follow him around Kennedy
Why do all of these weird uh Unsolved
Mysteries go in One Direction right you
know it's like Epstein will never really
know and like uh the server will never
really know the Dos a will never really
know it only goes in one direction to
protect Elites and people in power now
I'm sure there are a lot of people who
have gone to prison for cocaine
convictions and now cannot get jobs
wish that law enforcement had just gone
well you know we couldn't figure it out
we just went ahead and closed the case
but their lives were ruined for much
less and turned upside down so I'm
looking at this going man this is just
an epidemic in DC and you know obviously
there are some some threads that connect
here and it's very clear that the person
who leaked the Dobbs decision from the
Supreme Court is a Coke Hound who was
taken it to the White House and is very
powerfully connected notice how they
never find the culprit in either of
those cases yeah that's right that's why
it only goes in One Direction Only In
One Direction you can figure out you can
figure out who's behind anything like
this Tyrus if you try to figure out who
it helps yeah I don't I mean as a
Scooby-Doo alumni yes no he was you were
in Scooby-Doo yeah it was a Scooby-Doo
movie but the answers are already there
I feel like this is a bad fortune cookie
yeah we know whose Coke it is okay it
was the strippers that he murdered
buried in the new construction room I
know exactly what that is we know the
answers to all these riddles it's just
that they're not gonna they're not gonna
eat their own
the the FBI or the Secret Service
couldn't come out and blame somebody
they couldn't find a Fall Guy because
then it would have leaked so they just
said
we don't know and then we talk about it
for months we know it was Hunters anyone
who saw him on the balcony that night
they saw him that he had two hits during
that time and you know why he was you
know how you could tell you don't have
to watch him watch
the mom watch the good doctor staring at
the husband with her teeth like this
going get him off the balcony
something with your son that's all we
need to know yes so we can all rest
assure we can relax we know who's the
coke it was we know who did it it's just
they're not going to eat their own
they're going to say they don't know
every time they don't say they don't
know you go okay thank you that's all I
needed to know yeah I don't like the
coke shaming cat it's not about the coke
is it yeah you always say that yes uh
yeah also I think it's really
interesting that they decided to say we
give up after two what two weeks yes
that they never do that nobody ever does
that they're like okay that's enough
time they what they could have done is
just that we're working on it until
people forgot about it which is what
they do with it usually do that they're
like nope this one this case is just too
tough to crack yes the best in law
enforcement we put in two weeks and we
can't do it there's no way we ever will
well to be fair when you're holding an
investigation and you pull the entire
White House staff in there and you sit
them down individually and you put the
spotlight on them and you say who is it
and they all give you the same rehearsed
answer it's frustrating who was it
Hunters Hunters who was it Hunters the
best clip from the monologue was the
view because Joy Behar says this is just
the Republican conspiracy machine and
literally seconds later the other one
goes I bet you the Republicans planted
it yes right like no self-awareness no
that is beautiful it's so true so true
video of that what a republican just
wandering around didn't last time that
supposedly happened yes it was a bunch
of arrests yeah I mean this is I mean
shouldn't we be worried that in the
white house where anyone can enter in
the home of the president where the the
public has access literally anyone from
anywhere in the world can get inside
they don't have security cameras there
yeah yeah and the good news for big
Anthrax yeah exactly you can get
anything in there all right we got to
move on I know this is news to the
people on January 6th where that you got
20 angles of the same face hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else